the US ambassador to Germany has
criticized Angela Merkel's government
for refusing to join a naval mission in
the Gulf the US has asked its allies to
help protect vessels as they pass
through the Strait of Hormuz a proposal
the British government has agreed to but
Germany's Foreign Ministry has rejected
that request saying that priority should
be given to diplomatic efforts and to
de-escalating the situation
Richard Grinnell the US ambassador said
Germany's economic strength brings with
it responsibility to act here's how
Germany's foreign minister Heiko Maas
justified his position with the German
government will not participate in the
sea mission proposed and planned by the
United States we are in close agreement
with our French partners in this regard
we think the strategy of maximum
pressure is wrong we do not want a
military escalation we will continue to
work with diplomacy Germany's foreign
minister Heiko Maas they're rejecting a
u.s. proposal for a joint maritime
security mission near Iran meanwhile
Germany's new defense minister on elite
club Colin Bauer has struck a different
note saying no final decision has been
made we are considering this request in
close consultation with the United
Kingdom and France and we are doing this
with particular consideration of our
political and diplomatic goals and from
this overall assessment a decision will
be made well for now I'm joined by DW
security and international correspondent
Christian Christian we've got some
sounds like differing views there the
we've got the foreign minister saying no
we're not gonna help the u.s. in the
Gulf the Defense Minister saying maybe
which is it it's been confusing and
first of all it's a spotlight on how the
drum coalition government works these
days the German Foreign Minister mr. mas
is a social democrat and his party the
SPD in general is very reluctant when it
comes to sending the German forces
abroad military missions like that
envisaged now and pushed
by the US out of area missions are
highly unpopular in Germany and now we
have to step back a moment and take a
look at German interior politics the SPD
is not doing very well in the polls the
party is ailing so this has to be taken
into account to understand why the SPD
is pushing forward here the Ministry of
Defence is led by a high profile
conservative politician the newly
elected chairman miss con carne Bauer
and they say no we are still assessing
all at all options now you could ask
where is Chancellor Merkel she's on her
annual leave she's not in Berlin but
observers here take it for granted that
mrs. Merkel is backing the stance of her
coalition partner and that means no germ
participation in such a US measurement
so calm Cohen Bauer who many think might
succeed Merkel as the CDU's as the
Conservative candidate in the next
election she is trying to leave all her
options open anyway still some confusion
there
now last week before Boris Johnson took
over as prime minister in the UK the UK
proposed a European naval mission to the
Gulf to help protect shipping in the
Strait of Hormuz would Germany bought me
more amenable to a European mission I
personally think so and such a mission
under a European flag Germany would
probably find its role there have been
similar European missions in the past
some of them quite successful and jump
vessels were in that flotillas for
example there was one mission of the
coast of Eastern Africa an anti-piracy
mission but if you look at the Jang Navy
these days
there are so many vessels under repair
and undergoing an overhaul in process so
there are doubts if Germany would or
even could send ships into such a
European mission so there is some
speculation here in Berlin that Germany
might take over the reconnaissance
flights given given such a European
nation will be mandated by the Bundestag
the u.s. is really upping the pressure
on Germany to participate in a naval
mission there in the Gulf the
the US ambassador to Germany Richard
Grinnell coming out very strongly and an
editorial saying Germany needs to take
on more international responsibilities
but Germany's foreign minister says that
diplomacy is is prot is a priority for
this country and he doesn't want to
jeopardize that how is this diplomatic
track working out well it's not only
Germany it's Germany together with
France and the UK and these three
European powers want to keep at any
price the nuclear deal with Iran the
German government sees it as a huge
political mistake that u.s. president
Trump has unilaterally pulled out of
pull of that nuclear agreement so if the
u.s. now asks Germany to join a naval
mission there are doubts there are
questions raised here in Germany to what
end such a mission will be accomplished
if Germany perhaps might sleepwalking
into a war with Iran the German answer
is de-escalation and try to negotiate
try to keep the nuclear deal